[Music]
oh hi there
i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser report
what
a wonderful trip this has been
bitcoin at a dollar 2011.
right here on kaiser report we told you
to buy it it was going to compete with
gold
it's going to take over the world it was
in fact perfect
money and still is and will forevermore
be
well let's see how this is working out
stacy so
we were right jamie dimon was wrong and
yet jamie diamonds the guy who gets paid
a billion dollars to uh be wrong
all the time that's kind of how they why
the economy
is in a crisis is that these people who
are wrong all the time
keep on getting elevated uh to higher
and higher positions and they get
rewarded and celebrated as heroes
jamie dimon hated bitcoin at ten dollars
when we talked about it he hated it at a
hundred
he hated it at a thousand and well he
loves it at thirteen thousand
to show you how this has worked i'm
gonna show you a 2014
headline from rt jp morgan chase
ceo denounces bitcoin as terrible
predicts its downfall in the article he
says is a terrible store of value
it could be replicated over and over it
doesn't have the standing
of a government that was when 750
bitcoin was in the news so
he was saying it was a terrible store of
value
12 000 later like he's now his bank is
uh
pushing it and we'll get into that
headline right well he's not alone
in being a hundred percent wrong about
bitcoin there's nouriel roubini
paul krugman peter schiff uh and there's
the
whole list the stiglitz another nobel
winning
incorrect call on bitcoin and there's
still a huge and long list because
for the reasons that we said it was
going to
take over the global economy those
reasons have now been
accepted more and more by the global
population
jamie dimon is a guy who he
is defending the status quo he is
part of that front line to keep
real price discovery and real money out
of the system he prohibits a protector
of fiat money
and all the fake price discovery that
goes with it and all of the financing of
wars and corruption that goes with it
all the nickel and diming and
and failure to perform even basic
banking skills that go with it
the ability to pay off the billions and
tens of billions of dollars of fines
he's been
levied because of his law breaking his
recidivist law breaking over and over
again
and now his day is just about over i i
suspect he'll be retiring in the next
six to 12 months because
out of utter disgust and shame he really
needs to just leave so they were
fined 37 billion dollars over the past
10 years since kai's report has been
on air and we've focused of course in
that time on the crimes they were
committing
like the rigging of the precious metals
markets
we were talking about it in 2014 in this
article he does also point out he's
quoted as
saying that you know only criminals use
bitcoin
at the time we were discussing and
pointing out the
the evidence that there could be some
manipulation of the precious metals
markets by jp morgan we had experts on
who were pointing that out
and of course it was only in 20 26 years
later that the department of justice
were actually
building a ricoh case against them a
racketeering mafia-like case against
them and they settled and got to
get away with that but in the meantime
here 2020 after
you know they went up against us they
came up against us
using their orthodox thinking using
their
white ivory tower sort of thinking their
status quo thinking and that
they believe all the media hype around
them he believes the headlines when he's
put on the economist magazine or
one of these big influential magazines
the financial times and told he
saves the world well he believed that
we're lucky in that we don't
have that we have heterodox thinkers on
our show
we uh try to look at the you know a
contrarian view of what is actually
going on in markets
so now 2020 there's no choice for him
he's they can't
the the lies have just become so huge
the denial of what bitcoin was and we
have this headline for years
jp morgan was skeptical of bitcoin now
the bank's analysts
say its value could triple challenging
gold okay we said that years ago here
and now they're analysts who get paid a
whole bunch of money
to just look at kai's report and
repackage our content
into an a report that they charge their
investors tens of thousands of dollars
when you know they're saying oh it
appears that millennials
like bitcoin better than gold well
they're capitulating
so throughout the whole six seven eight
years that they've been down
you know bashing bitcoin you have to
understand that's just deferred purchase
right they they will be forced to buy it
eventually just like peter schiff will
and paul krugman and muriel roubini and
every every bitcoin basher will be
forced
to buy bitcoin at some point because
fiat money is collapsing and the world
is going from deglobalization
to extreme localism and the only way
that can work is with
the hardest money and the perfect money
and that's with bitcoin so if they want
to live on planet
earth and continue to live on planet
earth they will have to buy bitcoin
there's no if
ands or buts and the only the only
question is that what price do they get
in
will it be a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand four hundred thousand i
suspect peter schiff will capitulate at
000. paul krugman will probably
capitulate at around a hundred thousand
uh joseph stiglitz he'll probably
capitulate out of 250
000 but they're all the dominoes will
fall i am guaran 100
i guarantee you i guarantee that this is
a hundred percent
truth 100 capitulation
every bitcoin basher since 2009
will be going 90 to 100 bitcoin in the
next 18 to 36 months
i guarantee it and another important
thing about this
is it's the importance of doing your own
research
you know listen to the orthodox status
quo ivory tower sorts
take in their advice and listen to what
they say and then listen to somebody
like kai's report where we
try not to be too status quo promoting
and look at alternatives and so
obviously we were right i mean at the
time his daughter
i think her name was laura was famous
for buying bitcoin at that time she
obviously watched kai's report and uh
bought bitcoin because of us
right and add warren buffett to that
list still capitulate as well
i mean there are different layers of
sort of investors institutional
investors so like when
bitcoin hits 20 000 and takes out its
old
all-time high you'll see a whole bunch
of more conservative
passive investment money coming into the
sector
partly because that's the way they have
to do it they have to
wait to a certain price a certain size a
certain mark
market cap so that's part of the reason
why you're never going to get like
edgy um first mover advantage working
with somebody like jp morgan although i
have to say fidelity which is a huge
conservative
bank they were very early in on bitcoin
and in 2014 when
jamie dimon was spouting out that that
this was a terrible investment and a
terrible store of value
in fact fidelity which is a privately
owned bank it's not publicly because
abigail's a visionary abigail johnson is
the ceo of that company and she allowed
it to uh
happen right because she had the
intellectual capacity to allow the
protocol
to stimulate her in ways that got
fidelity involved in a major way she's a
under-rated major player in this space
people talk about michael saylor
they talk about jack dorsey over at
square
abigail johnson is actually the biggest
the first
major corporate executive to go long
bitcoin of
anybody in a huge way not only that they
went into mining
yeah bitcoin mining but you have to also
put that into the context of the time
her cohorts her competitors and what the
government of the united states was
saying at that time
at that time they were also agreeing
with jamie dimon and jamie dimon can't
think for himself he just says what the
government is going to say
and okay it's for terrorists it's for
bad guys it's for it and
it's evil don't use it within that
context is how she
stood out amongst all her peers and her
competitors
to move fidelity into bitcoin mining and
loads of research right a quick word
about how rising prices would increase
rising prices and that would boil down
to asset allocation
so there's about a hundred trillion
dollars floating
in the investment market around the
world
and um you've got the mounting managers
who
are guardians of that 100 trillion
dollars have to
usually go by guidance suggested by
asset allocation so they've got stocks
bonds property commodities
and they've been allocating to some
small degree on a microscopic scale
really
bitcoin but as the market value bitcoin
now hits a half a trillion and then a
trillion and then several trillion it'll
essentially show up on as a an asset
class
comparable to precious metals and then
that 100 trillion dollars by
the fiduciary responsibility by legal
statute
they must allocate to take advantage of
the total investment
opportunities globally and so that right
there
what triggers another multi-trillion
dollar rise in the asset in this case
bitcoin
yeah and let's tie those two together in
a final chart and a quote from that jp
morgan piece because they said
that the older cohorts i boomers and
above
prefer gold while the younger cohorts
prefer bitcoin as an
alternative currency said the jp morgan
research note
you know part of what we've been seeing
over the past 10 20 years
uh 10 11 years of us doing kai's report
as we said this intergenerational fourth
turning situation of the boomers
who created this amazing scheme for
themselves you have to give them credit
in 1971 when they were first coming of
age they
untethered the dollar from any semblance
of
wealth creation and they got to be first
in on a pyramid scheme it's a pyramid
scheme and we all know that and they're
lucky that they got to be the first ones
in
however as that disintegrates and
deglobalization starts because of also
the thucydides trap and
that's happening so fast because of the
policies that the boomers themselves
like clinton and and all his um
financial advisors like uh
robert rubin and larry summers they set
in motion the thucydides trap whereby
china would be able to rise so fast so
there's a lot of turmoil
that you know this election won't decide
but it's only going to
continue to accelerate because it's
already set in motion and you can't stop
it
so that is usually the time when you go
into gold so here's a chart to say
like well let's look at what gold versus
bitcoin are doing well
gold has not provided a hedge against
recent equity volatility
bitcoin meanwhile has crushed it and
that would go with
the volatility is being caused by the
collapse of the boomer
and the their rule of uh how they ruled
the world in the financial system that
is what's disintegrating so it makes
sense
that gold would not respond it would go
down with them whereas bitcoin
is the rise of the millennial and
generation z
and these generations coming up of what
they're they're going to inherit the
world and
it sounds like they might have a
positive impact right and people know
about program training
automatic training artificial
intelligence as bitcoin's relative
strength against gold
keeps extending for a greater duration
and at a greater amplitude the program
traders and the computer traders will
allocate more
there'll be more asset allocation on a
relative strength basis and that'll be
done without any
human being even making a move it'll
just be done by the computers
yeah but that's the status quo and
that's what jp morgan and
jamie dimon were listening to we were
out in the streets looking at the people
in the arab uprising
at the indignados at the at the uh
global insurrection against bankster
occupation so we were seeing this and
this is why we told you back in
2011 uh that bitcoin was the the new
gold
we said it was the currency of
resistance bitcoin we said that in 2011
and it would be funding the global
insurrection against banker occupation
and word banker that means jamie dimon
who will be out of a job
soon well we're going to take a break
and when we come back much more
coming your way
[Music]
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser time now to return to our
conversation with
dan collins entrepreneur extraordinaire
he was living in china for 20 years
became an expert been on the show many
times wrote the china money report
welcome back dan
hey max i wanted to pick up where we
left off
talking about ant financial set to be
the biggest ipo
in history chinese financial media it's
connected to jack ma
of course of alibaba fame and you
mentioned the statistic there
about in terms of the volume of business
they expect to
do and i think you mentioned 80 million
enterprises or businesses would be
hooked up day one to and financial
contrast that with jp morgan they did a
story that just came out that they want
to compete with scare
with a square so they're going to launch
a
card similar to square for payments
and when it launches they hope to have
all of 2 000
customers wow whoop-dee-doo
uh so anyway let's talk about ant
financial some more uh it seems like uh
this is in keeping with the theme that
china is at on
just a different whole another level
right now and
it wasn't kova that did it it's been
going on for years
and so give us enough talk more about
ant financial it's fascinating
the payment system and financial is very
important as we talk to ecommerce right
we're moving into the world of
e-commerce
china today their e-commerce about two
three times
literally what the united states is for
e-commerce a lot of that's been
developed by ant financial they came out
of alibaba
and financials connecting 80 million
merchants 16 trillion in transactions
last year
that's 25 times bigger than paypal more
importantly it's almost frictionless
frictionless e-commerce so they charge
0.01 percent
on payments you can't com compare that
to what
you're charging on uh credit cards here
in the united states
or if you wanted alibaba you know and
financials moved into loans so
very low cost loans over here we have
interest rate apartheid
credit card rates at all-time highs uh
amp financial is
creating a economic and financial system
for the people that's what they're kind
of focused on
creating that space where banks have
completely failed miserably
while they're going around you we saw
recently at goldman sachs at three
billion dollars fine for ripping off the
malaysian silver wealth fund
jp morgan has 25 billion dollars in
fines from 2011 to 2014.
you name it libor rigging hiding losses
fraud around toxic mortgages
and then everybody's favorite
manipulating the precious metals market
right that came out this year that's
almost a billion dollar fine
so while ant financial has been been
creating the new
financial and tech space our banks have
been going around
ripping people off they're cannibals
they're
like if you look i encourage the
listeners to just
google jpmorgan list of the fines it's
like a raptured
rap sheet for a serial killer i mean
anyone looks at this how are these
people still allowed to do business
they should be shut down well that's
what concerns me is
what that's what we know previously
what's going on now what's going to go
on the next 10 years
as we go into this system how much fraud
is going to happen
with these dinosaur banks in the u.s so
um and financial is kind of the model
just like huawei we kind of wake up whoa
what's china doing
that you know they have leapfroggers
technically they've leaked progress in
infrastructure
they're the aunt financial is now doing
it in the financial space it's going to
be the
largest ipo that's ever been seen it's
going to be worth half a trillion
dollars by next year so um
yeah i mean what's going on there watch
that space as you mentioned we've been
talking about it for years
now you bring up an excellent point that
you know i think needs to be flushed out
a little bit here so
we're told often that financial crime
is a victimless crime that when goldman
sachs and jp morgan are caught
breaking the law and if they pay a fine
and that should be sufficient eric
holder under barack obama
restructured the judicial system in
america
created a class of protected bankers
that were above the law
and by by decree and
of course that money printing that the
u.s has done
has masked the deleterious impact
of having runaway fraud and runaway
looting stacey herbert will often quote
the famous basquiat quote
of when looting became a way of life it
trickles down and becomes a permanent
structural feature of your economy
so now we're seeing the victims of this
by allowing these banks to
escape any penalty for 10 15 years now
we have allowed china to leapfrog
with ant financial and everything else
that comes with it to become the
dominant superpower in the world
it it it's not again it's it's an empire
the u.s empire committing suicide
not it's not that china is being
aggressively
trying to take over the world they are
taking they're becoming the dominant
superpower by default
because america has abdicated they've
walked away from the table
they stopped competing they relied on
money printing
and speaking of money printing the imf
calling for new brenton woods so
my mf it's a vestige of america and the
federal reserve and the
new york fed it's just a money printing
catastrophe
uh this new brent woods they're waking
up to the fact
oh my god we're about to lose to china
uh so
what will be the result of this new
brenton woods will china laugh
and just say well we've been buying gold
for 20 years and we think we have enough
gold to
support our economy we don't get we
don't care what you do or will they seek
a seat at the table or what's the
dynamic
there dan good question and uh yeah
we're living through historical times
right a new brent and brenton woods
uh the money what's more concerning to
me is
it looks like there's no stop to endless
money printing in the west
europe us there is no base case where we
get out of money printing
most of the non-chinese world has been
sucked into zero percent interest rates
us is the last one standing that hasn't
been stuck there but they're on their
way i think most people are predicting
that
that we're going to hit zero percent
interest rates as well the
payments to get out of this covent
crisis which has been boggled in the
west
is just going to continue to go leaps
and bounds what china will demand at a
brenton woods
is we've talked about this year as we
talked about the rise of the r b the
petrol u.n
oil the oil flows are now mainly to
china they're getting put into rmb
you're gonna the rmb is increasing fast
now it's back up to 6.7 or so
you know the rmb is gaining against
every currency in the world i think
eventually
the china has seen reason and they're
going to make the rmb
a equal partner in the world to the
dollar and the euro
and eventually people are going to move
to it because your telecom networks
chinese your electrical grid is going to
be chinese
your financial system is going to be
chinese because as you mentioned we've
abdicated we don't have it anymore we
don't
ge doesn't build power plants anymore
they trade eastern european loans
the the banks just go around
manipulating markets they haven't
created technical platforms to create
frictionless e-commerce in the united
states
we have a few standouts we have you know
your bezos
and your elon musk without you know a
guy like elon musk we still would be in
the combustion engine
trying to be eating her lunch in
electrical cars so um
yeah we're you know we need to step back
and look at that we are getting replaced
technically financially uh
it's gonna bleed into the military so
they're i mean it's a whole another
topic we could talk about but i would i
would say today
u.s has lost military supremacy in the
south china sea east china sea
that will go global over the next 10
years you know we've talked about that a
little bit on the show before
but uh where this ends up yeah i mean uh
how to even get out of the money
printing the us there's no
clear path how we can even escape it at
this point and it's not like this is
uh unknown for people around the world
we recently covered a poll which found
most people in developed economies see
china as the number one economic power
including germany where just 15 saw the
us
as number one and um you know so this is
an emerging story that nobody in the us
wants to talk about
on cable news it's msnbc fox news et
cetera this is not a story
because they're busy covering the
salacious
bedroom antics of the oligarchs and
their friends
around the world that's quite sad so
let's move on let's just
you know forget about the us it's now a
has been country let's talk about the
real stuff happening in the real country
of china
what's the latest on the belt and road
initiative how's that going
the delta road is just continued
unabated as you know
we've talked before it's a basically a
global
you know it's a basically a new lend for
lease across a lot of the developing
world especially central asia
it ends in serbia you talked about
countries looking at china
as a leader go talk to east europe east
europe you know china runs the 16 plus
plus one they own the ports in greece
they're building highways in montenegro
um you know they're going china's going
with one belt
you know not only across land but across
sea there's been a lot of
you know and a lot of its western
propaganda that's put against them that
you're falling into a chinese debt trap
but you know the developing world is
looking at this going okay but i'm
getting ports i'm getting electrical
grids i'm getting roads what are you
offering the us isn't around we can't
build any we can't build
infrastructure in our own country let
alone go out there and build
infrastructure in their countries
and china's coming table with money
know-how
engineers labor workers and
uh the new you know we're going to try
to build a nato
in asia against china but the rest of
the world is going to you know make the
decision what what's china going to
offer me and what's us going to offer me
this is part of the new cold war
thucydides trap
that we've talked about before right so
let's play a game here you now lead
america and you've got to deal with the
china
uh situation what would your policies be
i'd go through sector by sector i think
one of our weaknesses
has become our government leadership all
right these are not
smart people these are not well-informed
people
many of our institutions have failed us
we need to you know you need
we need to look at uh i would keep a lot
of the duties on china just to level the
playing field
uh against mercantilist economies that
would bring back
manufacturing that's at its core the
fourth industrial revolution is
happening which we're not even a player
that's networks factories
uh high-tech 3d printing we've got to
put
we've got to go back to having our
individual r and d labs so if you want
to money print let's go money print and
create
national r d labs like we used to have
the bell labs and let's do pure r
d we have to get our the accounting
system we have to look at we treat fixed
asset investments like chip plants
as as a curse on our balance sheets
right chinese subsidized chip plants we
subsidize sports stadiums
okay so there needs to be a whole
cultural shift back we need
real education we just we throw money at
things and we think that fixes the
problem it doesn't
so we throw money at health care costs
go off the charts we throw money at
education
higher education cost goes off the chart
we need real practical approaches
we need to step away from the ideology
to the left and right
we don't need to reinvent the wheel we
need to go around the world see what
works
and try to recreate our system our tax
systems archaic we tax productivity not
consumption
we're basically a consumption economy at
this point if you want money tax that
you got to get the financial books in
order of the country but once you bring
jobs back everything else will take care
of itself um
all the social problems will start to go
away and the country can be rebuilt but
we have to recognize we have a problem
our academic our our economists in this
country are an absolute failure
for 30 years they've talked about you
know pretending they know something
while they sit and look at industrial
belt cities just rot away
you know we're going to take a look at
the whole leadership is like soviet
union in the 50s and 60s they're all 70
80 years old been there for decades and
don't know what's going on and then
it collapsed so we're at a pre-soviet
youth collapse
clock is ticking dan collins for
president you got my vote
and after this show you're going to get
probably five or six more votes
congratulations thanks for being on
kaiser report
thanks max right and that's going to do
it for this episode
of kaiser report with me max kaiser and
stacey herbert want to thank our guest
dan collins entrepreneur extraordinaire
until next time bye y'all